And you know what?
Me too,
what really gets on my nerves.
We had a migration summit,
that's where the chancellor sits.
Are you listening well,
Mr. Göttingen?
They are also in a moment.
There sits the chancellor,
that's where the prime ministers sit together.
Thankfully,
the FDP will also
Proposal of the asylum seeker to address the benefit law
called and adopted.
And the only thing that comes 1 tomorrow later,
it is bled.
Mimimimimi,
how terrible everything was again.
Do you know what people expect in this country?
In these existential crises,
in internal and external security
from the largest CDU
CSU also has some understanding of the state,
that we work together here
and not this cheap opposition work.
There is baiting.
Mi mi mi mi mi!